nous a rejoint sur ce plateau guy mettan
journaliste et député au grand conseil
de genève guy mettan bonsoir c'est
justement à genève vendredi prochain que
sergueï lavrov le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe doit rencontrer son
homologue américain anthony blinken
dans ces conditions la rencontre elle va
encore tenir le dialogue diplomatique
continue ce soir
bon j'ai l'impression que cette
rencontre risque de tourbe l'anneau
maintenant parce qu'effectivement avec
la décision qui a été prise aujourd'hui
les occidentaux pour réagir comme ça été
dit d'abord par un nouveau train de
sanctions parce que comme ils n'ont
aucune imagination avec la seule chose
que qu'on sait faire en occident pour
quand on veut négocier cette prod des
sanctions à nokia allait à l'encontre de
la partie adverse je pense que ça va
continuer sa selle après la première
chose de effectivement on a construit ce
soir le constat qui s'impose son fonds
l'échec de la médiation européenne dans
ce printemps ça fait plus de dix jours
quinze jours que son président macro
s'en lavent seul soit d'autres s'y sont
investis dans la gestion ses prix ce
pont comme médiateur pour essayer de lui
trouver une solution et notamment en
régénérant les accords de minsk les
accords de mines sont morts parce que
les européens n'ont pas réussi au fond à
convaincre le président hélène ce qui
est de mettre en oeuvre ces accords donc
ce qui explique d'ailleurs la réaction
de la réaction russe ce soir en signant
ce nouveau traité d'amitié avec les deux
républiques j'ai l'impression quand même
que les négociations vont calais si vous
me permettez cette expression je vois
pas comment un sommet
option président poutine et byden
pourrait avoir lieu dans ces conditions
la rencontre monsieur l'arbre a fait et
blink n peut-être reste encore possible
mais je n'ai plus les plus sérieux
doutes